foreign
let's go out to uh Jenny in Chicago
what's up Ginny
Jenna hi what's up hello hello hi I'm so
nervous oh hi all right let's do this
let's sing our let's sing our favorite
song you go first go
I'm just kidding you don't have to sing
you don't have to sing nothing nothing
to be nervous about okay what's up
all right
I wanted to know how how I could talk to
my son about his biological father
I guess backstory is I was sexually
assaulted about five years ago and from
that I became a parent to an awesome
four-year-old I met someone
about three years ago and now we're
basically married we have a home
together we have another child together
my parents step my partner stepped into
the father role and although we used a
nickname for him instead of of dad like
when we had our next kid it kind of just
turned into him calling him dad like 24
7.
um now my child is four and he's kind of
wondering why his why his hair doesn't
look like our hair because his hair is
lighter and I'm kind of worried about
questions that he's going to ask I want
to be honest with him I don't want him
to grow up and have me break it to him
and he feels like his whole life is
alive but I don't know how to correct
him
um at this young age and I don't want
him looking for a biological father when
he's older
um
I don't want him to know the way he was
conceived he will
he will
um
wow there's a lot here
one of the core premises of this show is
that I want us to call a spade a spade
and I want us to all tell the truth all
the time
I also know that sometimes that's that's
um
borderline unethical because
normally it takes some time with
somebody who's hurting who's experienced
as much hurt as you have to establish
the level of trust necessary to get to
the place where I can say hey can we
just call this what it is
but because of this format is
everything's compressed and so can I say
some pretty harsh things real direct
that um I want you to know is it's me
with you okay but but for the sake of
people listening
um
even just out of the gate you chose some
language that it was very instructive
for me and I just want to point that out
to everybody listening is that okay
yes
often
in my whole career has been a big chunk
of my career was sitting with
um sexual assault victims okay
and with rape victims
and often I found not often but a a
heartbreaking amount of times women used
sexual assault because saying that I was
raped put them in a different category
they felt like it put them in another
category
um
but what happened to you is rape and
what happened to you was evil and wrong
right
can I tell you I'm so sorry
to to say it that way just because
something so great came from it right
like my my child came from from what
happened so I'm so grateful and I guess
maybe sometimes I don't put the real
heavy weight on it and my partner says
I'm guilty of like talking about things
very factually things that have happened
to me yeah there is there isn't there's
a defense mechanism right that I'm going
to talk about everything very clinically
and very distant so it doesn't affect me
I want to assure you beyond a shadow of
a doubt you're being affected
one of the core tenants
um in fact when this show when we're
done I'm going to send you a copy um
it's not out in the marketplace yet but
as soon as it gets out I'm going to send
a copy of my brand new book
um but
stage one of this wheel right this wheel
of being well is you have to own reality
and by minimizing one side of the
teeter-totter that is this experience
you were
had everything stolen from you
you were raped
that's one side of the teeter-totter
the other side of the teeter-totter is
you got the greatest gift of your life
this beautiful little boy
both of those things are your life
experience and they're both true in
squashing either one of them minimizing
either one of them your body pays the
price
see what I'm saying
yes
I'm so sorry that happened
so so so sorry that happened
okay when it comes to little boy
um
did let me say it is is bio Dad is he in
jail what's his what's his story
uh he is in the military so he's far
away from here and he actually doesn't
even know that my son exists
oh
that can't go on for very long
and you know that right
yes
um
man
did you choose to did you choose to not
make police reports or anything like
that
uh I mean I reported it with
it but that's
a different way of handling it I
understand
um my I myself was in the military at
the time so that was seemed to be the
easiest like Avenue to go through I
think you may be setting yourself up for
a major mess
if bio dad finds out X number of years
later that he has a child
um
man
let me ask you this hard question what's
the end game here
I guess I'm
I uh you know obviously want to be
honest with my child that is the most
important thing I don't want to be too
honest
um so let me let me the truth will
emerge
the truth will come out at some point
you are correct in not wanting your
child to find out the truth and then
find out that level of pain and hurt
and also find out mom lied to me
because in his entire world is in
shatters not just part of it
I don't think he has to learn the depths
of the
um
the depths of the crime committed
against his mom
but also it's not true to say your daddy
just left you because Daddy doesn't know
you exist and he may come back and try
to be the greatest father that ever
lived
and I would suggest that it's the court
of law
and I know you've been through it with
the military court and I know that's
such a zoo and I'm it's it's it's it's
it's
heartbreak on top of heartbreak it's
it's trauma on top of trauma
um when you get tribunal then nobody
believes you or they tell you oh we just
don't have like whatever he said she
whatever thing they're going to tell you
to make this thing go away
um
but you don't want to become a monster
in the process of trying to stay away
from a monster and not letting somebody
know they have a child
puts you in
not great company right now see what I'm
saying
yes okay
I do um and I know that's not what
you're calling but here's ultimately the
thing the story if Dad says I don't want
anything to do with this you take my
name off the birth certificate he's
getting adopted by this new guy fine
he does that then there is a plausible
conversation to have with your kid
yeah Mommy
um
that your daddy is
somewhere else he's in the military
why did daddy leave Daddy's was working
I mean we're gonna slowly have this
conversation over
um the course of X number of years and
as he grows up he's going to get a
little bit more a little bit more a
little bit more
but you don't want to be in the position
of lying to him and saying your daddy
left you your real dad left you your
real day doesn't exist or this is your
real dad this is your real dad and then
when the truth comes out when he does 23
and me when he turns 18 which he will
right or he'll be in some biology class
101 and part of the assignment will be
that every student has to do 23 of me
like it will come out especially with
technology the way it is
and so
a phrase I want you to keep in your
heart is secrets
destroy families
and so the the another layer of
complexity here has to be at some point
bio dad has to know there's a child
involved
and
if he says hopefully he won't says why
didn't you tell me you can say you know
exactly what I didn't tell you
and you can send a formal request from
an attorney that says you have a son
this guy wants to adopt your son
and go from there that can happen too
okay
thank you does that make that make sense
tell me what you're feeling is that just
awful that I ruin everything
ah I mean I definitely
I definitely interact with him I mean
but I do understand that um
putting things in place legally instead
of just
like just putting it down on paper is
definitely like a way to protect myself
in the future here's what you don't want
to have happen Okay coming back you
don't want to have a civil and or
Criminal suit filed against you that
said this woman made up charges against
me that by the way were found not guilty
in a military Court
and she hid my child from me for three
years for five years for 10 years for 18
years
she stole those years with my child away
from me
and you will have no recourse
okay
I don't want you to find yourself in
that position when he comes in and says
I want a hundred percent custody I found
out I've got a child that she was hiding
from me she's already leveraged false
allegations against me that was found
not guilty see what I'm saying like all
the decks gonna be stacked against you
and I don't want that to happen I'd much
rather you have an as best you can an
amicable interaction if you reached out
to this dude or if your attorney reached
out to him
um did you have any sort of previous
relationship with him or was this like a
uh an out of the blue raping assault
tell me about it
I I did have a relationship with this
person so I mean I had information like
let's say like a phone number or like I
know his Facebook or whatever obviously
without friends or anything but um I
have those like information if I needed
to reach out or if I had like legal
reach out if legal reached out or and
said you have a son via
Ginny and
uh here is the this person wants to
adopt this child
what would happen
I I really don't know
I think that has to be your direction
that has to be what you all decide to do
okay because I again I have
unfortunately sat with kids
who were told this guy is your dad or
this person's your mom they find out
when they're a sophomore in college that
that's not true
and I've had them sit in my office
across from me and they can't breathe
because everything they know is a lie
and at 18 19 21 24
there's those there's that anchoring in
that when all else gets sideways I trust
her I trust him
and if that goes away it's so that's why
divorce is is
so much it's like compound interest it
grows in how much it hurts kids because
they're in what they anchored into
doesn't exist anymore so it's like
cutting the string on a balloon they
just float up in the sky and some of
them make it some of them do great some
of them get tethered again it's awesome
many many
float around for years and years and
years and years and years
so I tell you that to tell you like
man the fastest path towards I I don't
want to engage with this dude I don't
want to have a conversation with this
guy we may we have a kid together
support him and pardon me
when it comes to the moment let me
answer this one question when it comes
to the moment if you ever feel I need to
tell him
there was rape and sexual assault
involved in this
in this one evening this one event that
led to me getting pregnant with you
I would strongly strongly recommend
getting with a
counselor that works with teenagers when
you would have that conversation or with
young adults and letting that person
who's trained in how to have those
conversation conversations lead that
conversation
okay there's people who are very gifted
and they create relationship and they
create what they're doing is they create
new things to Anchor into so that when
they pull the plug on what was that
kid's just not again cutting the string
and just floating off into space
they're very very talented at what they
do
um my one of my closest buddies um she's
Dr Lynn Jennings she'll sit with a kid
whose dad maybe murder somebody or is in
jail
and she will build a relationship and a
rapport with this kid over time and then
say that is here and then it gets a
little bit daddy hurts somebody really
bad and then a little while later it is
daddy took somebody's life
I want you to remember this too this is
really important
kids
understand that half of them is Mom and
half of them is Dad wherever mom and
wherever dad happens to be
right so if Dad's a monster the
instantaneous response as well I've got
that and I'm part monster too
and that's really tough for a kid
you can tell him you are not your dad
you would you're nothing like that you
would never do that
um that's where a child counselor is
really really helpful
on the day-to-day with him just being
only four like do I even say anything at
all or four is four is really young four
is really young okay
um
but it goes real fast four becomes five
and six and seven very very fast
four is why does my hair look like this
and all y'all's hair look like that
you say well let's draw a picture of it
I like your in in and you can begin to
take ownership you can teach this kid to
take ownership of how he looks how
beautiful he is how cool his hair is you
could teach him how to take ownership
without answering any questions
and then you could say like well let's
look at our feet let's see how our feet
look right so we're gonna anchor into
some concrete truths but we're not gonna
say
you've got another dad somewhere here's
why because that Dad doesn't know he
exists and you want to be able to say
um after you've communicated with Dad
either through legal means through an
attorney or directly you make a phone
call
um
you want to be able to communicate and
say Here's how your dad responded when
he found you're alive and I'll tell you
it will be hell on Earth
to have to hold in one hand what that
man did to you
and in the other hand
have that guy two rows over at a school
play five years from now
or that guy turns out to want to be the
best dad that ever existed
and rolls out of his appointment in the
military and gets into something else we
can be closer and wants to be plugged in
with the life of his son all those
things it's a very real possibility
your pain and your hurt
cannot bleed over into
punishing your son for what his dad did
see what I'm saying
yeah and that's it God Almighty that's a
a gross
awful mess
I'm just sitting here and I wish I could
hug you I know you're not here
I'm sorry
does it feel like a lot
foreign
yes I'm asking you just feel like too
much
um
we've we've talked about having my
partner adopt
um my son for a while actually so it's I
knew it was kind of coming out of me I
don't exactly know the formalized
process but I knew it was going to have
to come back in my face at some point I
don't know the laws of Illinois
I do not believe that it's legal
anywhere
to not tell somebody that they have a
child
and to legally adopt that child out to
somebody else without giving notice
I might I might be way wrong on that but
I don't think I am
if there's some absenteeism if somebody
bails takes off
my understanding is there's a there's a
formal process to say Dad disappeared
my guess is you probably signed some
papers that said dad was absentee is
that right
oh yeah yeah
that might get you into trouble down the
road
because Dad may not have been absentee
dad didn't know
mm-hmm
and I want you to know I totally
understand 100 agree with why you did
what you did
I appreciate that I don't think you're a
terrible person I think you were doing
exactly what a rational person would do
and say I don't want a monster in my
life I don't want a monster around this
new baby I don't want a monster around
at all
but I don't want you to break the law in
the process
okay
all right
thank you listen call me anytime Jenny
I'm going to be sick to my heart with
you and for you
um yeah call me anytime if your new
husband wants to call have him holler at
me
um
I'd recommend like honestly if I'm you I
would hang up the phone here and I would
call a friend who's an attorney
and walk them through
what you've done what you've signed
where things have been and get their
wisdom and advice on where to go next
yeah
make no mistake the truth will emerge
someday
all of it all of it
and let's be on the right side of being
people of Integrity even when it's
blindingly hard like this situation
because you don't want that that kid
who's now a young adult to look at you
and go you two
we don't want that
thank you for being a great mom Jenny
call anytime